estas declaraciones fueron hechas esta
mañana en el parlamento por el
viceministro de relaciones exteriores
iraní a bashar así que también fue uno
de los principales negociadores de ese
acuerdo nuclear en el 2015 y quien
estará este martes en viena reunido con
los cinco países restantes de este
acuerdo para hablar de las condiciones
iraníes de arak si dijo que será una
reunión netamente técnica porque la
posición de irán ya se conoce ellos
exigen que estados unidos levante la
totalidad de las sanciones económicas
impuestas por el gobierno de donald
trump y así irán podrá empezar a volver
a cumplir esos compromisos de los que se
fue retrocediendo después de haber
impuesto estas sanciones por parte de
washington el viceministro también habló
de que no habrían unas negociaciones
escalonadas o por lo menos una vuelta al
acuerdo nuclear escalonado como se ha
dicho y dice y rectificó lo que ha dicho
el líder supremo de la revolución ali
jamenéi que al fin y al cabo es el que
dicta esas políticas de que se tienen
que levantar totalmente las sanciones
económicas pero para entender esta
posición
radical de irán también hay que
entenderlo en el contexto de la disputa
política que hay en el país donde el
sector más radical se opone a cualquier
acercamiento o conversaciones con eeuu y
también al regreso al acuerdo nuclear